[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa al espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas en torno a la pandemia
del cob y 19 en nuestro continente a
continuación el sumario de temas que
tenemos para esta emisión vamos a
comenzar con una noticia positiva la
organización para americanas de la salud
informó que ha comenzado a notar una
tendencia a la baja en el número de
nuevos casos en varios países de la
región de américa latina' vamos a dar un
vistazo a esta tendencia esta semana
también hubo varias manifestaciones en
ecuador por parte de los médicos post
grad istas es decir los que están
cursando una especialización pero que ya
están ejerciendo como médicos sobre todo
durante la pandemia del comil 19 en ese
país
ellos reclaman el pago de sus salarios
por parte del gobierno desde quitó la
capital ecuatoriana vamos a estar
ampliando este tema y después de haber
combatido con firmeza al coronavirus y
también de llevar varias semanas con
cierta apertura social y económica hay
un incremento considerable de los casos
varias provincias canadienses con
nuestra corresponsal en la ciudad de
montreal vamos a ver en detalle cuál es
la situación de ese país norteamericano
donde hay una gran comunidad hispana
comenzamos
pues ya les decía yo que vamos a
comenzar con algunas cifras alentadoras
porque después de la apertura social y
económica varios países como brasil
colombia méxico y perú están comenzando
a registrar una leve disminución en los
números de casos de contagio lado ms
también confirmó esta semana que ha
habido una disminución considerable en
américa central excepto en los países de
costa rica y nicaragua recordemos que
brasil colombia méxico y perú siguen
siendo uno de los países más afectados
en la región por la pandemia del cobi 19
pese a este leve retroceso por ejemplo
el gobierno de la ciudad de mexico
mantiene la alerta naranja en colombia y
en perú se mantienen las medidas como el
uso obligatorio del tapabocas evitar las
aglomeraciones y también mantener el
distanciamiento social derecho que las
cifras bajen no quiere decir que la
situación esté mejorando
y a lo largo de esta semana los médicos
post grad istas es decir quienes ya
tienen un título médico pero están
cursando una especialización y por la
emergencia sanitaria fueron contratados
por el gobierno de ecuador para trabajar
en los hospitales públicos para hacer
frente a la pandemia han manifestado un
descontento en las calles de diferentes
ciudades de ese país suramericano
gustavo ortega en la ciudad de quito nos
va a entregar más detalles de lo que
está sucediendo allí porque no solamente
hay manifestaciones por parte de los
médicos gustavo cuéntenos qué es lo que
está pasando hoy en ecuador y ya que se
deben todas estas múltiples
manifestaciones
sí muy gran noche para ti santiago
básicamente en las protestas que se han
venido generando en el ecuador están
focalizadas el rechazo de la ley
humanitaria el nuevo texto legal fue
aprobado la asamblea nacional y a pesar
que tiene algunos puntos positivos como
la reducción del 25 por ciento de las
pensiones educativas de igual forma
también la prohibición del incremento de
los servicios básicos como el agua de la
electricidad de igual forma también la
posibilidad de renegociar el pago de
deudas y créditos de igual forma también
la imposibilidad de incrementar los
servicios como la electricidad el agua
el internet durante un año inclusive el
juego del 2022 también es percibida de
manera negativa el ejecutivo nacional
asegura que esta es una ley para
proteger el bolsillo de los ciudadanos
pero también para proteger el empleo
este es el enfoque positivo que hace el
ejecutivo en nacional y a los aspectos
positivos que tiene la ley pero de igual
forma también es percibida de manera
legal
porque el texto legal también plantea la
reducción del 50 por ciento de la
jornada laboral de igual forma también
la reducción del 45 por ciento de la
remuneración de los trabajadores también
se plantea la creación de turnos
temporales y todas estas propuestas del
nuevo marco legal puede inclusive
aplicarse durante un año con la
posibilidad de renovarlo un año más por
el cual esto también ha generado una
serie de protestas no solo de los
médicos pegaditas sino en distintos
aspectos como también los educadores los
estudiantes los trabajadores que
progresivamente han venido saliendo a
las calles santiago gustado ya usted lo
estaba mencionando y yo lo dije en la
introducción del tema los médicos post
grad east asia hay cerca de 2000
renuncias de ellos en los diferentes
hospitales públicos de ecuador porque
están protestando porque también
protagonizaron hechos de violencia sobre
todo frente al palacio de calor
carondelet en el centro de quito a lo
largo de esta semana
pero básicamente los médicos post grad
istas están protestando porque exigen el
cumplimiento de la normativa básicamente
también y acá en la ley humanitaria
también les afecta porque la disposición
8ª de este nuevo marco legal establece
que los médicos progresistas formarían
funciones como personal regular de los
distintos centros hospitalarios recuerda
que durante la emergencia sanitaria se
ha requerido de mucho personal
aproximadamente son tres mil trescientos
médicos progresistas que existen en el
ecuador la mitad de ellos por lo menos
son autofinanciados y la otra mitad son
becados y también conversación que hemos
tenido con su presidente santiago su
única él dice que hay un retraso en
cuanto al cumplimiento de esta ley de no
han recibido los contratos requeridos
también hay otras exigencias que tienen
mucho más atrás de sus luchas laborales
luchas sociales como también la
disponibilidad de financiamiento de
becas de distintos de mayor plazas para
poderles así
de especialización que ellos han dicho
que también no se ha cumplido la ley
reclaman que había dinero para pagar
deudas externas pero no así para
responder a la necesidad inclusive
también pudimos seguir a uno de los
médicos por adif as donde también
expresaba que muchos de ellos han tenido
que seguir y arriesgar su vida
cumpliendo labores en zonas
específicamente de sectores kobe porque
básicamente reciben algún tipo de apoyo
financiero también pudieron conversar
con el psicólogo fernando cornejo el
realizamos estudio en toda la región no
solamente en ecuador en argentina en
méxico en chile donde hay un estudio que
revela que por lo menos el 50 por ciento
se ha incrementado las asistencias y las
citas de carácter psicológico porque los
distintos especialistas también sufren
de estrés y de algunas dolencias de tipo
mental de igual forma también pudimos
ingresar a otro centro de especialidades
temporales de atención kobe
específicamente donde se revelasen por
lo menos el 40 por ciento de los médicos
desertaban porque
y no podían sobrellevar estas atenciones
santiago que la mayoría de los sistemas
de salud de américa latina gustavo han
estado al borde del colapso y hace falta
muchos médicos y por eso se han visto en
esta situación es en parte entendible un
poco la exigencia que hacen los
sanitarios en ecuador en este país
ya terminó el estado de excepción hay un
nuevo panorama en este país en torno a
la pandemia se mantiene las medidas la
alerta sigue sobre todo porque los casos
se siguen presentando como está entonces
el panorama y en ecuador
bueno panorama básicamente es el
levantamiento del estado de sección ya
no hay un recurso jurídico para poder
renovarlo desde la declaratoria de la
emergencia sanitaria el estado de
tensión lo cual implicó la aplicación de
una serie de medidas básicamente se
levantó en estado de sesión desde el 12
de septiembre ya no se podrá renovar la
ejecutiva nacional no tiene como
renovarlo legalmente pero se traslada
ahora las responsabilidades a la
ciudadanía en este momento se ha
iniciado una campaña que se llama yo me
cuido donde básicamente se está
otorgando las responsabilidades de
cuidado personal a la ciudadanía pero de
igual forma también ya ecuador apuesta a
la reapertura de la economía y el
escenario poco a poco viene
'siento de la aprobación inclusive de
dos planes pilotos para el reinicio de
clases
y telecom y en todo el país santiago
gustamos muchas gracias por este reporte
y este análisis desde quito ecuador-
contándonos cómo está la situación en
ese país nos vamos ahora hasta honduras
porque allí se mantiene la saturación de
los hospitales públicos por cuenta de
los casos de kobe 19 esto mientras
también está avanzando la construcción
de algunos hospitales móviles un proceso
que está avanzando muy lentamente y
también es señalado por los sobrecostos
y sobre todo por varios casos de
corrupción las denuncias ya fueron
hechas ante el consejo nacional
anticorrupción de honduras así están las
cosas
el padre de esta joven hondureña murió
por falta de atención médica en el
pasillo de un centro de salud hasta
donde fue llevado porque no encontró
cupo de los hospitales que se encuentran
colapsados por la emergencia del cob y
de 19 cuya varios hospitales públicos y
ninguno menos pero me atender
luego fui a hospital privado igual me
decían que no había poco en ninguno de
los hospitales lo único que mencionaban
que no había cupo después decidí ir a un
centro de salud y ahí me lo ingresaron
pero ninguno de los doctores me lo
quisieron tocar en ningún momento a mí
me decían que yo hoy te hagás con
semillón no me le quisieron dar los
primeros auxilios ni na aunque yo le
pedí le rogaba que por favor que él se
me estaba muriendo para resolver la
crisis sanitaria el gobierno de honduras
compró siete hospitales móviles a
turquía por 47 millones de dólares pero
de acuerdo a investigaciones del consejo
nacional anticorrupción el costo real de
los hospitales es de 14 millones de
dólares por lo que consideran que hubo
sobrevaloración en la compra
además sólo dos hospitales han llegado
al país y aún no funcionan aprovechó hoy
la oportunidad para solicitar a la
procuraduría general de la república y
alves h que puedan conjuntar toda la
información para poder analizar los
incumplimientos en el contrato de los
hospitales que ya están en el país y los
otros hospitales que todavía falta que
lleguen por su parte del gremio médico
hizo sonar las alarmas ya que como
prueban estas fotografías tomadas
durante la investigación del ministerio
público parte del equipo médico
entregado con los hospitales viene en
mal estado mire estos hospitales según
lo que nos han dicho
1 y son cosas que ya se investigaron y
hay suficiente documentación venían con
material que era no solamente de segunda
que era material de desecho ya ni
siquiera era un equipo de en buen estado
era basura prácticamente lo que venía en
los contenedores y mientras esperan que
los hospitales móviles entren en
funcionamiento los enfermos o
sospechosos por kobe 19 acuden a los
centros de triaje instalados
provisionalmente por el gobierno para
paliar la crisis sanitaria que atraviesa
el país el segundo en centroamérica con
la mayor tasa de letalidad por la
pandemia
pero en venezuela los pacientes con
otras patologías
todos los esfuerzos
el riñón que le transplantaron a jessica
solórzano hace menos de dos años corre
peligro la cuarentena por kobe 19 ha
afectado seriamente el despacho de
medicamentos de alto costo por parte del
gobierno y los pacientes no los están
obteniendo a tiempo esta situación que
empezó con la crisis económica de
venezuela se ha venido agravando con las
sanciones de eeuu al país es básicamente
una sentencia de muerte para nosotros
porque no tenemos cómo comprar los
medicamentos y el seguro social no nos
da de una desesperación un miedo
constante de que el día de cualquier día
puede resultar el órgano porque no
tienes los medicamentos
estefanía lugo de 9 años tras un
trasplante de hígado hecho con la
donación de 70 mil dólares tiene un poco
más de suerte porque una fundación le
está dando los medicamentos más
importantes aún con esta ayuda es
difícil para su madre costear el resto
del tratamiento por la situación
económica
está costoso la alimentación es parte
del tratamiento de ella porque su
alimentación debe ser balanceada muy
sana muy rigurosa en ese sentido y bueno
con los ingresos que percibimos tenemos
que hacer maraña las decenas de personas
que acuden a diario las farmacias del
gobierno y se van con las manos vacías
ya comienzan a tener consecuencias
alexander hernández pacientes con
parkinson dijo que recibe reportes
mensuales de que están muriendo de 5 a 6
personas con esta condición médica por
no poder tomar sus medicinas
hoy ocupa 7 partidos yo tengo 10 seguir
con la condición que es lo que
interrumpir tratamiento que aúne pago
muscular tan fuerte que te pueda un
pariente estirar un paro respiratorio y
espero que el rba de los pacientes está
sufriendo hoy en día el mayor temor que
tienen los pacientes crónicos en
venezuela que visitan farmacias como
estas es que no pueden seguir sorteando
las dificultades y que tengan que pagar
esos tratamientos lo cual causaría un
daño irreparable en su salud y los
llevaría incluso hasta la muerte termine
fernández france24 para más
y mientras tanto los trabajadores de la
limpieza de los hospitales mexicanos se
exponen al virus cada día para facilitar
el trabajo del personal sanitario el
país cuenta con altas cifras en cuanto
al personal de salud que ha fallecido
durante la emergencia de la pandemia del
cob y 19 asimismo méxico también está
entre uno de los países con la mayor
cantidad de casos en el mundo
son la invisible primera línea de
batalla frente al cob y 19 trabajan en
los pasillos y sótanos de los hospitales
mexicanos desinfectan áreas críticas el
cogen material infeccioso lavan miles de
sábanas y batas cada día a menudo con
menores garantías laborales que el
personal sanitario
esta limpiadora sabe que su función es
vital para facilitar el trabajo de sus
compañeros pese a los riesgos tienen más
este desechables
amnistía internacional destacó en un
informe la particular situación de
vulnerabilidad de los empleados de la
limpieza de los hospitales frente al
contagio debido a que muchos son
subcontratados por lo que cuentan con
menores protecciones está soldado de 23
años reivindica el esfuerzo de estos
operarios sin nosotros no desinfectamos
bien un área no hacemos la limpieza bien
pues hay más
puede haber algún riesgo no entonces
haciendo nuestro trabajo bien
colaboramos con esto la crisis sanitaria
sorprendió al gobierno mexicano con un
déficit de 240 mil médicos y enfermeros
pero también con un personal de limpieza
escaso para una emergencia de salud en
la que las medidas de saneamiento son
primordiales en la lucha contra el
coronavirus sigue avanzando la apertura
paulatina de la vida social y económica
en muchos países de américa latina
argentina se mantiene en cuarentena con
excepciones pero sobre todo en la región
metropolitana de buenos aires la capital
ya lo hemos dicho varias veces en este
programa es una de las cuarentenas más
largas del continente y del mundo
colombia y guatemala han regresado de
manera escalonada a la actividad
económica ya la vida en exteriores
colombia reanudará este fin de semana
los vuelos internacionales con las
primeras conexiones aéreas a eeuu
mientras que guatemala reabrió la
operación del aeropuerto internacional
la aurora que sirve a ciudad de
guatemala abriendo así una ventana de
conexión con el exterior venezuela
continúa con un confinamiento llamado 7
por 7 es decir
siete días de confinamiento y luego
siete días de apertura de manera
sectorizada república dominicana
mantiene restricciones como el toque de
queda nocturno en santo domingo la
capital y paraguay allí las autoridades
sanitarias solicitaron al presidente
mario abdo benítez que extienda por dos
semanas más la cuarentena social o fase
3 que finaliza este fin de semana para
las regiones de asunción que es la
capital y para los departamentos de alto
paraná central concepción y caaguazú
mientras tanto canadá allí están
preocupados por parte de las autoridades
sanitarias ante el constante aumento de
los casos de contagio que se han venido
presentando en este país en las últimas
semanas en donde temen que una segunda
ola de propagación del coronavirus sea
mucho más mortífera que la primera que
tuvo ya ese país vamos a conversar con
rebeca guard nuestra corresponsal en la
ciudad de montreal para conocer más
detalles
hola rebeca y qué motivos ha dado el
gobierno canadiense para que se esté
presentando este aumento de los casos en
las últimas semanas
gracias santiago pues es una buena
pregunta por un lado se temía que eso
iba a pasar la economía canadiense ha
estado abierta durante varios meses pero
las temporal temperaturas fueron más
altas durante nuestro verano y los
estudiantes y algunos trabajadores
estaban de vacaciones ahora las escuelas
han abierto y ahora que el clima se está
enfriando las actividades al aire libre
se están llevando a cabo a cabo en el
interior pero funcionarios provinciales
y federales también han culpado a las
personas que no siguen las medidas de
seguridad especialmente a aquellos que
están haciendo grandes reuniones
privadas y fiestas en familia y con
amigos sin máscaras y sin
distanciamiento social
rebeca y cuáles son las zonas que tienen
más riesgo en este momento ya el
invierno está a la vuelta de la esquina
en canadá y eso complica un poco más la
situación por las bajas temperaturas
claro claro bueno que de dario tiene
actualmente el mayor número de casos
activos seguidos de columbia británica y
alberta y el miedo también ha aumentado
y esta semana ha habido informes
mediáticos mencionando filas
excesivamente largas en algunas
estaciones de prueba incluidas varias
aquí en montreal
con estas alertas que ha emitido el
gobierno canadiense las conferencias de
prensa que hubo esta semana en ottawa
alertando sobre esta situación qué
medidas entonces van a tomar en este
país para empezar a mitigar el número de
casos
bueno el interesante es que en canadá la
mayoría de las medidas específicas se
tomarán al nivel provincial aunque el
gobierno federal también a distintos
fondos adicionales entonces por ejemplo
ahora en septiembre los funcionarios en
ontario y en quebec han anunciado ha
anunciado nuevas medidas en ontario han
reducido el número límite de personas
permitidas en reuniones privadas y han
aumentado las multas por incumplimiento
y aquí en quebec han anunciado nuevas
multas para las personas que no usan
máscaras en espacios públicos cerrados y
varios líderes provinciales provinciales
han advertido que si los casos que
continúan aumentando van a implementar
aún más medidas una diferencia
interesante estévez es que hasta ahora
los líderes han centrado su atención en
acciones individuales que la gente puede
tomar para evitar una gran segunda ola y
para evitar que la economía y las
escuelas vuelven a ser a cerrar
rebeca llama mucho la atención que
canadá tiene una frontera común con eeuu
de más de 8 mil 800 kilómetros es una
frontera enorme con múltiples pasos
fronterizos y eeuu es el país con la
mayor cantidad de casos de contagio de
kobe 19 y con una alta tasa de
mortalidad también como he hecho canadá
para mitigar un contagio masivo a través
de los puntos fronterizos porque además
recordemos que la gran mayoría de las
ciudades grandes de canadá están en el
sur del país muy cerca precisamente de
la frontera con eeuu
si no es un tema muy interesante bueno
hay muchos factores que podrían insular
e influir discúlpame en la diferencia
entre los dos países y el sistema de
salud canadiense es público a diferencia
del estadounidense tenemos una población
mucho más pequeña y los gobiernos han
estado brindando mucho más ayuda directa
a las personas que perdieron su trabajo
debido a kobe pero es verdad que tenemos
una gran frontera y la percepción de que
está completamente cerrada es falsa hay
personas más allá de los trabajadores
esenciales que viajan entre los dos
países aunque muchas personas personas
todavía pueden cruzar la frontera una
cosa que el gobierno en canadá han hecho
de manera diferente es imponer una
cuarentena estricta y monitoreada de dos
semanas para las personas que entran al
país no hay cuarentena obligatoria en la
otra dirección claro hay que añadir
rebeca la disciplina ciudadana los
canadienses han respetado las medidas
que ha impuesto el gobierno porque hay
pueblos que son atravesados por la
frontera que de una
y otras están en un lado o en el otro de
uno de los dos países muchas gracias por
este análisis y esta información desde
la ciudad de montreal rebeca where
nuestra corresponsal en este país
norteamericano vamos a seguir en esta
región porque el presidente de eeuu
donald trump anunció que para antes de
que finalice el año 2020 su país contará
con cerca de 100 millones de dosis de
una posible vacuna contra el cob y 19
este es un anuncio que contradice
completamente a los expertos de salud de
su propia administración en washington
esto sí en plena campaña presidencial su
rival el demócrata joe biden aprovechó
este anuncio que hizo el presidente para
criticar su credibilidad y pues esto es
una muestra más de pandemia versus
política
ante un comité del senado el director
del centro para el control y prevención
de enfermedades de eeuu robert redford
responde a la pregunta sobre cuándo
habrá una vacuna disponible para todos
los ciudadanos estadounidenses
y creo que habrá una vacuna que
inicialmente estará disponible en algún
momento entre noviembre y diciembre pero
un suministro muy limitado y tendremos
que tener prioridad
si me preguntan cuándo estará disponible
en general para el público
estadounidense de modo que podamos
comenzar a aprovechar la vacuna para
volver a nuestra vida normal creo que
probablemente estamos hablando de
finales del segundo trimestre o tercer
trimestre de 2021
poco después el presidente de donald
trump contradijo el director del centro
sanitario prometiendo que para antes de
que finalice el año en el país serán
distribuidas 100 millones de dosis de
una vacuna contra el joven 19 y hemos
fabricado todos los suministros
necesarios para que tan pronto como la
fd apruebe la vacuna y como saben
estamos muy cerca de ello podamos
distribuir por lo menos 100 millones de
dosis para finales de 2020 y un mayor
número muy pronto monitorea el candidato
demócrata a la presidencia joe biden lo
atacó
seamos claros confío en las vacunas
confía en los científicos pero no confío
en donald trump y los estadounidenses
tampoco pueden confiar en él en este
momento tiene aquí tipo que medido el
afán del presidente parece estar ligado
a intereses electorales cuando faltan
menos de dos meses para los comicios
presidenciales en los que se juega la
reelección por ahora las farmacéuticas
pzifer modernas y astrazéneca llevan a
cabo estudios de la vacuna que ya está
en la fase 3 pero aún no han entregado
su producto a la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de ese país que
debe dar su visto bueno y garantizar la
seguridad del producto
en nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa
el presidente de guatemala alejandro
giammattei fue diagnosticado con kobe 19
hasta el momento el mandatario no ha
dado detalles sobre los síntomas o si
carece de ellos eso sí indicó que va a
continuar con sus labores en
confinamiento él se convierte así en el
segundo mandatario de centroamérica
después de juan orlando hernández de
honduras en ser contagiado con kobe 19
en otras noticias el mundo alcanzó esta
semana 30 millones de casos de contagio
de coronavirus este anuncio tiene lugar
cuando europa vive una segunda ola
preocupante para las autoridades
principalmente en alemania francia y
españa lado ms indicó que todavía falta
mucho para vencer a la pandemia
claramente así lo están indicando las
cifras de contagio
en otros temas destacados de la semana
las autoridades de argentina
descubrieron la venta ilegal de terrenos
a través de redes sociales terrenos que
fueron ocupados o comprados por cerca de
2.500 familias que llegaron a vivir a
ellos a estos terrenos de manera ilegal
debido a que no podían costear los
alquileres de sus viviendas este es el
informe desde la ciudad de buenos aires
plástico madera cartón y latas estos son
los materiales con los que miles de
familias construyeron casas improvisadas
en un terreno baldío de 100 hectáreas
muchos menores de edad viven aquí con
sus familias entre todos tratan de
compartir e intercambiar comida o las
pocas posesiones que lograron conservar
la crisis sanitaria acentuó la crisis
económica que ya estaba instalada en
argentina personas de bajos recursos
quedaron en la calle por eso muchos de
ellos decidieron instalarse en este
terreno desocupado y por la pandemia me
quedé sin trabajo y no puedo pagar más
de killers me quedé lavalle porque mis
cositas fui vendiendo para la carpa del
alquiler hasta eso me fui vendiendo mis
propios muebles mi tele mis cosas para
irme guarde mi heladera y una cosita
para una casa donde un amigo mío y yo
estoy acá el primer día que se hizo la
toma de este agua porque no tengo en
dónde ir necesitamos un lugar fijo para
poder tener mi familia
porque quizás tengo un día de trabajo y
al otro día pero no tengo para pagar
alquiler pero no tengo nada para comer
solo en recesión económica desde 2018
argentina se encamina a una fuerte
contracción del 12% este año debido al
impacto de la pandemia que ha elevado
los niveles de pobreza y desempleo las
autoridades argentinas anunciaron que el
terreno ocupado será desalojado a partir
de la próxima semana además recibieron
denuncias de estafadores que intentaron
vender parcelas en este lugar a través
de las redes sociales según datos del
gobierno argentino cerca de 36 millones
de familias no tienen vivienda lo que se
traduce en un aumento de las ocupaciones
temporales en todo el país las
autoridades de la ciudad de la paz en
bolivia anunciaron la construcción de un
nuevo cementerio dado que el actual está
saturado esto coincide con la alta
mortandad que está dejando la pandemia
en ese país suramericano por otra parte
un grupo de empresarios locales
inventaron un práctico horno crematorio
portátil
[Música]
el cementerio de la paz es la última
morada de más de 100.000 fallecidos pero
ya se acaba el espacio de 450 entierros
mensuales en tiempo normal paso a 2.150
en julio cuando la ciudad enfrentó el
pico de la pandemia de kobe hemos tenido
dos mil 150 servicios aproximadamente de
los cuales 250 han sido cremaciones y
con un 1900
servicios de entierro entonces en cuanto
a la capacidad del cementerio hemos
podido atender este pico ante la falta
de espacio la alcaldía buscó un terreno
para construir un nuevo camposanto cerca
del barrio paceño de pura pura pero los
vecinos del lugar se oponen ellos
aseguran que el terreno elegido debe ser
parte de un bosquecillo en lugar de un
cementerio que pegan otras posibilidades
no somos gente indolente nosotros
también hemos pasado en esa situación
del tema del cori y la necesidad de
donde nuestros familiares vamos a llevar
la incineración de cadáveres en bolivia
creció durante la pandemia ante el
desborde de las muertes por eso unos
empresarios inventaron crematorios
portátiles de 2.7 toneladas su coste es
de 45 mil dólares y se han vendido media
docena a igual número de municipios es
una alternativa que le hemos puesto a
bolivia y al mundo para poder ayudar en
lo que es trasladar el horno del día a
distintos lugares y poder brindar el
servicio según el gobierno por causa de
la pandemia murieron más de 5 mil
personas sin embargo los análisis
independientes señalan que sólo hasta
fines de julio había un exceso de 14.000
muertes atribuibles al coronavirus unas
muertes que necesitan sepulturas dignas
hay controversia en perú por una campaña
de publicidad dirigida a los ciudadanos
que no obedecen las reglas para mitigar
el embate de la pandemia esto enfureció
a los ciudadanos peruanos la campaña
hace parte de una estrategia del
gobierno nacional para concientizar
sobre el avance del coronavirus pese a
la apertura social
mareo pensó que visitar a su mamá era
seguro su mamá ahora saben que no lo fue
el kobe no mata solo no seamos cómplices
esta es la campaña del gobierno peruano
que busca un comportamiento responsable
de sus ciudadanos ante la pandemia de el
coronavirus que es fundamental que son
duros pero es necesario para que
reflexione las personas que se resiste a
cumplir y también lo de su entorno para
que los hagan tomar conciencia pero la
estrategia residuos duras críticas en
redes sociales y contrario a los
esperados por las autoridades indignó a
muchos y polarizó a los peruanos el
gobierno ha asumido que metiéndole temor
a las personas acá tengo un poco más las
leyes pero también tiene la contra que
generando problema puede aumentar puede
generar más obra de la que ya estamos
viviendo es tuvieron que tomar un poco
más de tiempo para agarrar una
información bien concreta y así informar
más a la población que darles miedo tú
le das miedo a una persona y la persona
se angustia y hace cualquier cosa puedo
sobrevivir o no totalmente la tiene la
culpa el gobierno
aquí quien tiene la culpa es el pueblo
peruano que no tiene la conciencia ni la
responsabilidad de cuidarse cada uno
para el analista en comunicación
política luis benavente la campaña
estigmatiza una parte de la población
encierra un concepto equivocado
básicamente culpando a un segmento de
peruanos de clase media baja clase media
clase media baja como los responsables
de las infecciones lo cual es
estigmatizar a ese sector de peruanos
mestizos tal como lo representa la
campaña como que si la clase alta y los
blancos de clase alta no fueran también
irresponsables los peruanos se esperan
que la vacuna contra el hobbit 19 no
demore mucho y si todo sale bien tendrán
que seguir luchando para recuperarse de
la recesión que vive el país
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa puede dejar todos sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales yo los espero la próxima semana
con otro resumen con las noticias más
destacadas en torno a la pandemia de
kobe 19 sigan cuidándose por favor nos
vemos
[Música]